faire le point avec stéphane lauzon il
est secrétaire parlementaire de la
ministre des aînés bonsoir monsieur
lauzon soir donc on dit que l'argent a
été envoyée aujourd'hui à quel moment
les aînés canadiens peuvent-ils espérer
la voir là c'est à partir du 8 juillet
les montants versés directement dans
chacun des comptes c'est-à-dire pour la
première vague à ceux qui ont la
sécurité vieillesse en 300 dollars et
ceux qui sont éligibles pour le
supplément de revenu qu ils 200 dollars
de plus à partir du 1e juillet oui ça
fait presque quatre mois monsieur lauzon
que la pandémie a touché le canada
pourquoi ça a été sinon avant d'envoyer
ce soutien aux amis vous savez on était
état par état sont les premiers qui ont
été touchés ce sont les entreprises des
travailleurs
las crédits publics laissé à celle des
gondi venus en aide aux fouilles à
mesure que cette padilha ce qu'on a
entendu pendant la pandémie c'est les
années en demeurer en sécurité en
restant à la maison mais seul entraîner
des coûts supplémentaires c'est pour ça
qu'on a pallié on a aidé les
travailleurs les étudiants situer des
sites et aux deux aînés aujourd'hui on
est fier de pouvoir aider les aînés pour
les coûts excédentaires
oui effectivement c'était une aide qui
était attendu d'ailleurs vous aviez
annoncé ce programme là c'était début du
mois de mai là on est en juillet vous
avez déjà dit qu'il fallait prioriser
inversement on avait appelé sa de l'aide
d'urgence
ça ne semble pas tellement urgent quand
ça prend deux mois entre l'annoncé le
versement est ce qui a eu des pépins et
pourquoi ça a été plus long
non si la mécanique que la mécanique de
données inversement à tous
ce sera encore plus compliqué si le
monde est différent selon le revenu
c'est pourquoi on a décidé de donner à
tous les aînés de 65 ans et plus qui
sont éligibles à sculpter le vieillir
sur un montant de 300 $ à tous et ça
facilite un petit peu le processus parce
que pour ya pas un système arrow
gouvernement et fait renvoyer de
l'auberge ans donc on doit on doit
travailler avec les systèmes qu'on a en
place et on a priorisé tous les autres
d'où silva
avant de donner l'argent aux années
parce que les aînés n'étaient pas
nécessairement couper dans les revenus
n'étaient pas nécessairement touchés
directement par la perte d'emploi pour
certains peut-être mais dix étaient très
minime
donc on a décidé de venir quand même
donné un petit peu mais aux aînés mais
on en a pris aux et les travailleurs les
entreprises vont fermer
donc votre calcul monsieur lauzon
gouvernement sait que les aînés
financièrement au moins souffert de la
pandémie votre calcul c'est c'est sa
forme akouala les dépenses
supplémentaires auxquels ils ont pu
faire face merci des défensives et liées
à l'épicerie ou livraison
prenez par exemple dans des centres
privés les familles avaient pas accès à
apporter le rapport aux années dans leur
chambre donc ont dû payer du personnel
additionnel dans notre sens c'est aller
jusqu'à 8 de leur part souper pour être
livré à la chambre annoncé les plats et
les ramener pour pas que l'aîné et
besoin de se promener de toucher les
poignées de portes et de de propager la
maladie
donc on a isolé les 1/2 heure qu qui
était relié à ça mais aussi leur
coopération de coups d'épée c'est dû aux
transports
il ya aussi les médicaments qui ont été
livrés certains endroits c'était les
médicaments est affectueux ouais bon
dans ce cas ci est monsieur lozès un
versement unique il ya plusieurs
programmes
on avait annoncé une certaine durée ça a
été prolongé on pense à la pcu par
exemple est ce que dans le cas du
soutien aux aînés ça pourrait être
renouvelée ce que pourrait y avoir un
autre chèque mais on a déjà eu un faux
souvenirs la première quand on a dit
qu'on a entendu quelques mois pour des
années mais dès le début de la pandémie
ce qu'on a fait c'est qu'on ne donnait
un crédit de tps que toucher beaucoup
d'aînés autour d'eux au delà de 4
millions délai au canada qui ont reçu un
montant d'argent dès le départ donc pour
certains qui ont le sentiment de revenu
garanti aujourd'hui on peut parler d'un
couple d'années que mon va se revoir
dans l'ensemble 1500 $ pour un combi
herbe depuis le début donc on y venait
au début
et à la fin de la pandémie et c'est pas
la fin au dernier au dernier recours du
processus pour donner aux années quand
on regarde le ch est là par exemple pour
ceux qui touchent le supplément de
revenu garanti 500 dollars c'est quand
même assez peu c'est ce sont des gens
qui touchent des revenus très faibles
pour être admissible au supplément de
revenu garanti faut gagner moins de 18
mille 600 $ pour une personne seule
est-ce que ça va vraiment faire une
différence un chèque de 500 dollars par
mois
en fait 500 dollars une fois ou avait
bien que le gouvernement est déterminé à
répondre à cette promesse électorale on
me dit qu'on n'est en aide aux aînés la
priorité au moment où on se parle c'est
cette crise et pas des millions
d'urgence maintenant on va penser à
travailler pour les aînés pour la suite
et effectivement il ya peut-être des
annonces moyenne mise à jour économique
ou pouvons appelons la comme ça un
portrait de l'économie qui s'en vient on
va surveiller ça cette semaine
entre-temps évidemment il ya des
organisations je pense à la fadoq par
exemple qui réclamait qu'on bonifie le
supplément de revenu garanti mais qu'on
bonifie le versement mensuel 50 dollars
par mois est ce que c'est quelque chose
qui pourrait être envisageable ça ben
oui c'est tout tout est sur la table au
travail avec les autres on a des centres
des nez partout à travers le canada on
est à l'écouté on est en consultation
moment ceux conçus par des puits
la ministre fait en sorte qu'on puisse
apporter le maximum de renseignements
possibles au cabinet 2010 la préparation
du prochain budget maintenant on est à
l'écouté puis on est parfaitement
conscient qu il n'y a pas eu
d'augmentation de revenus de pension
depuis très longtemps pour les uns et il
faudra alors on attend votre annonce
mathieu en une sur mer s'est beaucoup
apaisée
merci beaucoup